only on CBS this morning bone Appetit
magazine is revealing its 2018 hot 10
it's a list of the country's best new
restaurants look at that gorgeous cover
sort of says it all beautiful picture
beautiful paper stock it's a distinction
that changes the lives of restaurant
owners Joe and Katie kindred learned
that firsthand when their eatery was
named number 7 on the list back in 2015
Bon Appetit called kindred which is in
Davidson North Carolina a casual
southern restaurant that studied abroad
the hot 10 helped kindred thrive and
enabled a couple to open a second
restaurant nearby here's a look at their
story when we open kindred we had a
healthy fear of like you know what what
could happen I mean we put everything on
the line we knew that it had to work
we open in February which is not really
the best time
I distinctly remember a couple weeks in
being like oh my god did we just make
the biggest mistake by five yeah we had
a meeting like right before the hot 10
came out and like we were like we were
not in good shape we were treading water
who were told like barely I think we
were told we have to make or we have
certain amount of man you know $35,000
in sales at the time we were doing like
20
we've got looked at each other and we
were like okay how do we get there being
in the hot 10 it forever changed
kindred I mean it forever changed our
family forever changed our team without
that article who knows where we'd be
we're super thankful because literally
our business tripled I mean it went from
like $20,000 a week to like $60,000 a
week like that welcome to Hello Sailor
I think it's 100% based on kindred
success I mean without kindred we
definitely in my opinion wouldn't have
Hello Sailor
there's a lot of power in that list it
pushed me as a chef it made me want to
be better it really motivated us